tout de suite il est 8h30 c'est le
journal avec Anne-claire Coudray un
poignard
avec cette image regardez
impressionnante et inquiétante d'une
trombe marine elle a été filmée dans une
station balnéaire sur l'île de Chypre
cette Méditerranée qui n'a pas fait de
victime et bien c'est former à cause de
la chaleur inhabituelle des eaux de la
Méditerranée en cette fin octobre
peut-être un nouveau signe et même
sûrement du dérèglement climatique qui
multiplie les phénomènes extrêmes entre
1900 et 1990 un seul mois d'octobre
avait dépassé la moyenne des 15 degrés
et entre 90 et aujourd'hui elle a déjà
été atteinte huit fois un marqueur du
changement climatique où les vagues de
chaleur sont plus fréquentes plus
intenses plus longues les années comme
2022 pourraient se répéter
les gars et je les ai mis à quoi il y a
même pas un mois sérieux comme vous le
voyez les pâtissiers Mercotte a prévu
une dégustation très flippante
bienvenue au jeu donc on a du
déguisement de sorcière après libre à
vous si vos enfants préfèrent se
déguiser en reine des neiges en pompier
ou en docteur j'en sais rien quoi vous
pouvez réussir
[Musique]
et il a porté plainte moi j'ai peur des
fantômes
des fois dans les couloirs quand il y a
du vent ça fait ouh ça souffle je suis
un ça fait un peu peur donc
si jamais agréable de voir des fantômes
je pense mais ça va pas non
[Musique]
[Rires]
on me dit qu'il arrive dans un instant
pour fêter les bons scores de ce début
d'année notre président Franck à
[Applaudissements]
savez-vous que c'est en ce moment la
récolte des glands on envoie un paquet
dans les médias depuis 48 heures des
glands oui en octobre les forestiers
partent à la chasse aux voilà donc ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle et j'ai trouvé
un petit endroit où on peut en dégoter
quelques-uns on va le voir tout de suite
oh non oh non mais qui a fait ça bah
alors ça c'est vraiment je suis saboté
aujourd'hui
c'est la chaîne des animaux il y a
beaucoup de programmes sur les animaux
je demande un petit programme cours sur
ma chatte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dans le vocabulaire qui décrit une
cloche on va parler de la tête de la
cloche on va parler de l'épaule de la
cloche on va parler de la robe de la
cloche ou de la panse de la cloche
en anglais on va parler des lèvres on va
parler donc on a vraiment un vocabulaire
qui est très très proche d'un être
humain mais être blonde c'est une
responsabilité
parce que je pense que quand tu es
blonde on te regarde même quand tu
passes juste tes dos c'est je l'ai dit
toujours que des fois tu es blonde dans
une voiture une fois j'avais la perruque
blonde que j'avais pas levée et il y a
des voitures qui passent et qui
regardent même si je savais pas qui tu
es parce qu'il a blender attire
ah le loup là il se calme quoi
vous avez même appris à faire le cri de
la bergère
je sens que c'est une demande
et là il y a 200 moutons qui arrivent
tous tout ça
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la caserne d'Ali Baba ici pardon
on a bien entendu est-ce qu'on peut
rembobiner au régime c'est la caserne
d'Ali Baba ici on a bien entendu
Alibaba c'est quoi un pompier c'est la
caverne d'Ali Baba ma chérie oulala il
faut reprendre les bases